(Dixieland jazz music)
- [Host] Ah, Amsterdam:
the canals, the weed, the bikes.
There are a lot of bikes here.
(speaking in foreign language)
Yeah, they're everywhere.
Wait, what?
(splashing)
(speaking in foreign language)
There are 165 canals in Amsterdam,
totaling over 60 miles in length.
And resting on the ground in these canals
are bikes, lots of bikes.
(speaking in foreign language)
These two guys, they're bike fisherman.
They pull bikes out of
canals in Amsterdam.
(speaking in foreign language)
(rattling)
I'm just gonna ask the obvious:
Why?
Why are there so many bikes in the water?
(speaking in foreign language)
The machine they use is basically
an oversized claw machine.
It goes into the water
and pulls out bikes.
Most bikes are found near
the edges of the canals.
(speaking in foreign language)
And what happens after they're removed?
(sonic beep)